Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it tonight. We're
going to hear a very powerful story
because there is power in the blood of
Jesus Christ and there is power in our
testimonies and that's how we're going
to overcome in these last days. And I
can't wait for you to hear this story.
Check this out real quick.
This woman looked happy. She looked
free. She looked confident. But none of
it is real. This woman lived for
attention, run from pain, and hid behind
an identity that almost destroyed her.
And I know that because this woman was
me.
Until Jesus opened my eyes. Until he
broke the lie I was living. Until he
gave me a life I never thought I could
have. That old identity die. I didn't
transition out. I was rescued out. My
name is Diego and this is my testimony.
Wow. away. Powerful testimony. I cannot
wait to get into this. I got my brother
Diego in here right now. Thank you so
much for coming on, man. I saw this
video on Facebook on one of the reels
and like that day I looked you up and
the next day you were getting back to me
and here we are just a couple days
later. Thank you so much for coming on,
man, and sharing your story. How How are
you?
>> Hey, how are you doing? Um I'm doing
amazing. Thank you so much for um you
know g uh just giving me the invitation
to be here. It's a it's an honor and
praise God for, you know, like what he's
doing.
>> Amen. I'll I'll be honest, you are the
first person we've had on to share their
testimony. We do a lot of kind of uh
prophetic things, conspiracy theories,
and where political things are, how
they're tying into prophecy and things
like that. But when I hear powerful
stories like this, man, I want to share
it with the world. Um, you know, I I've
had God's done a lot of great things in
my life and I love to just I love
personal testimonies. I love hearing
them. And so, man, I just can't wait to
hear your stories. So, I purposely
didn't watch any stories uh any of your
testimony on other channels. I saw it at
least on two or three other channels and
I was like, you know what? I want to be
surprised. I want to hear it for the
first time. And so, I really just want
to sit back and and let you do most of
the talking. I know a lot of times
people share testimonies on other
channels and I I look in the comment
section and people are telling the host,
"Man, shut up. Let them tell their
story." And so I want to I want to do
that. I want to be respectful of your
time and I want you to get to share what
God is doing, what he's done in your
life, what he's doing in your life, and
where he's taking you. And so just tell
us from the very beginning of this
thing, did you grow up in a Christian
household or how was your life growing
up? How did all this start?
Yes. So, um well, I'm originally from
Peru and um I we've I grew up in a
Christian home. Yeah, definitely. We
were Catholics um when I was a kid. Um
but um once we grow up, well, once I
started growing up, um we became
Christians.
>> But see, this is the difference. We were
not like um um like we we didn't have a
relationship.
>> It was more like a religion kind of
thing.
>> Gotcha. And so yes, I grew up that kind
of with that kind of environment. And um
well, it all started I believe when I
was six, which it's when my dad passed
away.
>> Um when my dad passed away, there were
so many things happened in my h in my
home.
>> Yeah.
>> And so we were very broke like broken
for what just happened and especially my
mom
>> because we were three by then and we all
were ch children. So, uh, my mom had to
take care of us. She was going through a
lot of stress and, um, she was very
depressed a lot to the point that we
didn't see her much. She was all the
time in her room crying and probably
thinking in suicidal thoughts. Well,
that's what she told us later on when we
grow up.
>> Um, but that was the kind of home I I
was living for several years. um we had
no much attention from my mom because
that's what she was struggling with and
the enemy was attacking her so much. So
I mean she still sent us to church which
was which is good I believe. Um we we
>> we went to church constantly even though
she didn't want to join us because she
was struggling so much um we decided to
go. So um I believe that's where the
enemy entered a lot to bring us so much
confusion not to me only but to my
sister and to my other brother attacking
us in deferient areas with me of course
was with homosexuality and as you guys
you know probably already know like I
was a transgender woman and so um well
it it all started like that kind of way.
So um um I remember when I was in
kindergart no not kindergarten but like
um um I don't know how do you guys say
it in English here like um when you go
through
>> elementary school
>> yes elementary school yeah that's
>> so um that's when things is starting to
get more um uh well where the enemy use
it you know to to bring more destruction
to me to bring more confusion um I was
um at in my class you know like just
listen to what the teacher was saying
and I remember this kid being next to me
uh who we've been friends for a little
bit um but then uh out of nowhere he
literally showed me his part and I was
very
>> in class
>> confused. Yeah, in class we were I was
sitting in the back. He was sitting in
the back and so yeah, it was very
awkward. Um I just didn't know how to
react. I was like like should I tell the
teacher? should I just keep it to myself
or like uh what was his intentions? I
didn't know and I still probably don't
know but um
>> I was very confused and so after that I
remember just um next day a few days
happened and I just couldn't get that
out of my head like why why was that you
know like um but then few days happened
and I remember I was this math class
which it was really hard at that moment
and I just wanted just to go to the
bathroom and I asked my teacher hey can
I just go to the bathroom and he said
like all right let's go And so I
remember clearly that inside of my head
I was like, I hope he follows me
>> cuz I want to know what the same guy.
>> All right,
>> the same the same little kid. We were
both kids. All right, I was like um
>> yeah, like seven or like six or seven.
And he was I think all one one year
older than me.
>> And so um I was just so confused. I
didn't know what was going on but I just
wanted to see you know because I
>> since that day I start having more
attention from him and since I didn't
grow up or I didn't have the attention
that I had in my home I was looking or
in other places but without realizing
you know cuz you don't think those
things when you're a kid
>> um so I went to the bathroom and I
remember that the kid following me and
um he asked me like like, "Hey, I want
you to put your pants down." And I was
so confused. I was like, "Why?
>> Like, what's going to happen?"
>> Cuz I was very naive. All right. I had
no clue what he was trying to do. I was
just very curious. Um and so I didn't do
it because I was so like
>> I don't know. I was afraid. I guess I
was scared like why?
>> Um and I remember he just was like,
"Okay, just turn around. Let's um I want
to do something with you." And so um so
he started mimic you know the things I I
believe that he watched or saw at his
home um now that you know I'm an adult
>> and um so he started doing things like
sexual movements and I just started to
feeling very like like I don't know very
very confused and since that like since
that like uh after that event happening
um I couldn't take that out of my head
so every single time I see him at like
at class I I just was staring at him all
the time. Like I was so um so confused
but at the same time I just wanted more,
you know. And so uh within time I just
started thinking like, "Oh, maybe he
likes me, you know, or maybe he I just
want to have his attention cuz it feels
good, you know." And so it was not more
like about the sexual part, but he just
it was more like I want to have the
attention, you know. And um of course he
just realized like this is not right.
This is not okay. And so um I I don't
know he stopped talking to me. It was
like really awkward and I felt horrible,
you know, because that was the first
time I
>> I received rejection, you know, like
that like was very clear that I received
rejection and in within time after that
event happened happening um I start
feeling more confused, you know. Um I
remember that before I met this kid, I
used to like a girl who it was we were
in kindergarten. He was very innocent,
very naive, but it was it was beautiful.
It was cute. And all my friends used to
bother me with her. It was just so
silly, but it was cute.
>> Um, and so that's why I believe that the
enemy, you know, uh, like opened the
door and he destroyed that that, um, he
used that little kid and, um, bring so
much destruction into my life. And so
after that, after time passing, like I
just uh start going to middle school and
then to high school, um things start to
get worse and worse
>> um to the point of like just hating
myself of because of what I was
thinking, what was going into my mind. I
I started to realize that what I was
thinking, it was not holy. It was not
good. It was not what, you know, God
designed it. And so, um,
>> I do want to ask,
>> it's just,
>> so you you were in like junior high,
high school. Did you have any other
crushes on females at that point or or
were you looking at guys at that time or
what?
>> Yes. So, um, after that little girl, you
know, like we I I didn't see her no
more, so I had no contact with her at
all. So I I was too focused on like what
happened with that boy that um I wanted
to have that attention again with other
boys.
>> And so I was so focused on like just
wanted to have the attention for for
boys. Um
>> okay
>> cuz that's what I received most. Um
because girls it was just different like
by that time they were just like being
friendly or they were my best friends
but nothing I I didn't have that same
feeling or at least that's what you know
I felt at that moment
>> right
>> um but yes within time as I grew up I
start having more crush more crushes you
know like I start falling like not
falling in love but just to like this um
you know like a boy the way the way they
give me more attention
um I've you know the more I start
growing the more attention I wanted from
men and um it it was not something that
crossed my to my mind like oh it has to
be probably from my home because I'm not
receiving it like this just came up like
literally when I gave my life to Jesus
like oh okay I understand what's going
on now like I understand what the enemy
was using
>> so um
>> in middle school things is starting to
get you know and sorry in high school
things start to get really really uh
crazy just because I wasn't naive
anymore. Um I I was introduced to
pornography when I was 13. Um and so of
course you know all the sexual stuff and
starting coming into my mind. So it
wasn't only about attention, but it was
more of sexual
and it was only with boys. Like I just
like I just imagine having sex with men
and like things like that, you know. And
so I never share none of these things to
my family because I was so ashamed of
what they were going to say and
especially to my mom because I knew she
was struggling so much
>> and so like it was I was very
embarrassed for what I was going
through. Isn't it interesting that we
know innately, you know, God's law is
written on our hearts and we know things
are wrong. Even as a kid, you know, if
you
>> as a little baby,
>> if you steal something from another kid,
you know, like you're going to get in
trouble for it or something. And um so
we we really know right and wrong.
>> And um I'm curious how old you are.
>> Uh I'm 24 now.
>> Okay. So I was Yeah. So you grew up in a
time period where there's the internet
and everything. this a lot of this stuff
was starting to become more and more
acceptable. You start seeing this stuff
on TV a lot more. Probably gay marriage
is probably legal most of your life. Um
but you still knew that this was taboo
and it wasn't right. Something wasn't
right about it.
>> Yes. So in Peru it's very well not right
now but before you know it was very
close-minded especially at the time that
I grew up with that I grew up um it was
very close-minded like when they were
talking about gays or things like that
like they just
>> so much bullying and as well like it was
like like kids didn't share that. Um at
least in my high school like we're very
very like which was very conser
conservative. Um,
>> so um, but kids already knew like all my
friends already knew that I was like
they
>> they were like calling me gay constantly
and like you know bullying me so much.
So I believe that that affect more you
know that affect me more. I was um to
hate myself to just be like okay it is
you know um this is not right like what
you're feeling is not right what you're
going through that people hate you
because the way you act and so I start
having like bitterness towards myself
>> and um I remember cuz you know I told
you that was Christian so uh during that
whole process I still go to church you
know I still went to church I still went
knocking doors and telling about Jesus
>> uh while I was in my soulful life, you
know, cuz watching porn and over
thinking about becoming a girl or
wanting to become a girl without
thinking that was a possible like a
possible thing. Um cuz in we never well
at least where I grew up we never talk
about like there's such a thing of
transitioning or no not at all.
>> So um
I I used to pray to the Lord like I used
to pray God why did you make me this?
Why you did you make me a man if you
knew that I struggled so much with this
identity? Like why? And so I cried a lot
constantly. And I remember when I was a
kid, I used to tell him like, Lord,
please make me a woman. Like I made me a
woman. I know you can do it.
>> And because I've hear all these stories
about Moses and Abraham and all the
miracles he has done, right? And so I
believed in my heart as a kid that maybe
if he if he sees my pain, if he sees me,
then he will transform me to be, you
know, a girl that the girl that I desire
to be. And so
>> within time, I realized that that was
not going to happen. And so um I wasn't
praying anymore. I was just being more I
had more bitterness. The the thoughts
started coming heavy on me and be like,
you see, he doesn't love you. Like he
created you to be this way and look what
he's doing in your life. He knew that
you were going to struggle with all
these things and he still didn't care.
And so I started having bitterness
towards him. I start I just I I was so
mad at him because of the way he made
me. And so
uh on high school was one of the hardest
hardest hardest seasons of my life
because um I decided to um to share my
feelings to share what I was going
through. Um, I I I like this. Uh, I had
a friend in in high school that I was so
in love with him for like five years.
The whole the whole the whole high
school era.
>> Yeah. It it was I was obsessed like um
cuz we um pretty much were in school
since we were in middle school. So like
we were together together the whole you
know every single year. So um I was so
obsessed with him and I just wanted to
have his attention. Um, so we became
really good friends. We became best
friends at one point and I thought in my
mind that okay, he he likes me. All
right, he he probably likes me. So I
started thinking in my head like, oh
wow, like this is going to happen, you
know. Um, I'm finally going to show
share my feelings and things like that.
And um I remember like uh I I I start
seeing him, you know, um dating on other
girls and things like that. And it was
so it was so frustrating to for me to
see things like that cuz I couldn't
share anything of course like what um
especially when I started seeing him
dating girls and things like that. And
so I remember uh the enemy put really
really strong in my head to um make a
fake account to have his attention. So
what I did was um and I feel like before
I used to feel so embarrassed of what I
did and but right now I healed that area
because I I asked for forgiveness
>> what I did to him and so um I created
this fake account and I was wearing my
sister's clothes and I remember putting
pictures of myself with just different
angles so they don't see that I was a
boy because you know yeah I was trying
my best you know um so I remember that
Um, I start like making that account
real. Like I just took to took some
pictures and I started following a lot
of people and then after that like I
waited for like few months like I just
didn't send the friend request right
away. No, no, no. I waited for a few
months for him to believe that I was
real. Wow.
>> And so
>> it's like a mission.
>> Yeah. It was like a whole like Yeah. A
whole strategy and things like that. And
and so
>> I was like this is going to work. This
is going to work. I was so excited. I
was waiting for the moment uh for him to
send me the friend request. And so time
passed and I was like, "Okay, I'm ready.
Let's do it." And so I I sent the friend
requests and immediately he answered and
um we started chatting. We started
talking every single day
>> for hours. Like I remember going back
going to bed at like 3:00 in the
morning, 4 in the morning, just
>> talking and texting and texting and it
was it was that good that he wanted to
meet up
>> and I knew that that was going to happen
at one point. So after I think few
months talking and texting um I was like
okay I'm gonna do it. I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell him it's me. I
think that at this point he's going to
like me because I have shared him
already my feelings and so we kind of
like mashing up and like somehow it's
going to work right and I know this is
so stupid but in my mind you know it was
it was going to work. All right. And so
>> yeah, because you're getting the
feedback you want from him, but you're
having to pretend to be someone else to
get that feedback.
>> Yeah,
>> exactly. And so it's just, you know,
like after that, like I remember he's
like, "Okay, we're going to meet
tomorrow." And I'm like, "Okay, let's do
it." I'm I'm uh I'm excited for it. But
this time I was like um I think two
I think it was like the last year of
high school. So I was like, "Okay, this
is going to happen." Like this is going
to happen. And um he's like, "Oh, can
you give me your phone number?" Well,
>> to you for WhatsApp because in Latin in
South America, we use a lot of WhatsApp.
And so he's like, "Yeah, give me your
WhatsApp." And I'm like, "Okay, sure. I
give him WhatsApp WhatsApp." And I
didn't think it twice. I just sent him
my WhatsApp and
>> I forgot to take my picture out. My
picture was back there.
>> Oh no.
>> And I was like, "Oh my god, no." I was
so like I It was not the way I wanted to
be.
>> Oops. Wrong number. Sorry.
>> Kind of thing. I was like, "Oh, wait."
Um, cuz he straight away was like, "Oh,
wait. Do you know Diego? Why are you
giving me his number?" And I'm like,
"Oh, no. That's my friend. I forgot. I'm
sorry." But he didn't believe it. All
right. He didn't b he didn't buy it. So,
I was like um the next day I was like,
"Okay. Uh, maybe he's going to believe
it. Maybe he's just going to forget
about it." I remember going back to
school
>> and um I see all these all my friends
like they were all looking and staring
at me like
>> no way.
>> And they start calling me like cuz I had
a fake name of course and they were like
oh uh the fake name was Kate. So they
were like oh welcome Kate I guess you're
here now. Like they all start making
jokes and like bullying me so much. I
was so so ashamed of what he
>> because he had told everybody.
>> He had told everyone not only my
classroom but like the whole school like
it was so bad and um and I was the major
of my school. So it was so bad for my
for for all because I used to go out
front and share you know like hey you
guys like you know I don't know like um
just to just to be up front and share
everything that was going on in high
school because I was the mayor and I
represent the school kind of thing. So,
just going up front remembering like
everybody calling me, "Oh, you're so
gay." And all this like um really bad
words
>> um that I'm not going to say here, but
yes. So, it was so bad and
>> I was just, you know, so so um upset of
myself of what I did, so ashamed. So, I
started crying and all I could do was
just run to the bathroom to So, I went
straight to the bathroom to the restroom
and I start crying. I just all I could
feel in my head is just like just kill
yourself. You're just curious of what
this is so embarrassing. You know, what
have you done?
>> And that's how the enemy works. All
right. He first tells you like, "Oh,
let's do this." And you know, like
you're going to love it. And then he
becomes and once you do it, he becomes
your worst enemy. Like he's like, "Oh,
what have you done? Look at you. You're
nasty." And things like that.
>> And so that's how I start feeling. I
have so much shame. And I call my mom
and I'm like, "Mom, please pick me up.
I'm feeling so sick." And I have never
called my mom. All right. Cuz she's
always a hardworking woman. So
>> she came and she's like, "Um, are you
okay?" And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah, I'm
okay." I was crying so bad. And she's
like, "I don't believe that you I don't
believe it that you are like sick. Tell
me what's going on. What happened?"
>> Um, and I'm like,
>> "Mama's always know."
>> Yeah. Exactly. And I was like, "Oh, I
don't want to tell you cuz this is going
to be bad. You're gonna kill me." And
she was like, and I and I told him. And
I told her after so many times she like
>> this is the first time you've ever said
anything about homosexual thoughts or
anything.
>> Yes, definitely. So my mom grabbed my
phone and she started reading all the
conversation
>> and it was so bad because in this
conversation we talk about so much about
sex and all their stats and and so she
was so in shock. She just couldn't
believe it. She was I don't know. Like,
so she was like, "You know what? Let's
go to your room. Let's go. Let's go to
your to your classroom. I want to go
there." I'm like, "No, no, please. No,
no, no. Let's just go home. Let's just
go home." And she grabbed me and she's
like, So, she went to the classroom and
she's like, "I don't want to speak to
this to this guy."
>> Wow.
>> Who's been bothering my kid?
>> And so, in front of the classroom, my
mom makes a show. She tells like, "Stop
bothering my kid." like I I just I got
that point. I just didn't want to exist.
And I know, right? Whereas
>> she's trying to defend you and
everything, but now it's just like, oh,
mama's boy. Um mama had to come in and
protect him or something. Oh, man.
>> It was so bad. And I was like,
>> um I think it was like uh seven more
months for for high school to finished.
Uh or yeah, almost there. I don't
remember that exactly time, but I was
like, "Okay, you know what? Just teach
me in high school, please, mom. Like, I
don't want to end up here. I don't want
to be here anymore."
>> Homeschool.
>> Of course, that didn't happen. I had to
swallow it and just keep going to high
school. Uh, but within time, people, you
know, forgot about it. But it was like a
lot a lot of like bullying after
bullying. Like it was so much hate. Um,
and after that, after I finished high
school, my mom was like, "Okay, I want
But this whole time, my mom is been
trying so hard to take us out of that uh
place we were living in." Cuz the place
we grew up, it was
>> kind of very ghetto somehow. So, she's
like, "All right, I have everything
done. We're moving. We're going to USA."
>> And, you know, yeah, I was like,
>> I was it was a huge move cuz I was like
I was, you know, I was ready to get out
of there like for real. Right. You know,
USA was like, "Okay, land of the door
open, you know."
>> Yeah, exactly. All right, let's do it.
I've always wanted to come to USA. I was
so excited. I was like, "All right, this
is going to be a fresh start. Nobody
knows. Nobody knows. Nobody nobody will
know that I'm gay or things like that.
Like, I'm going to start like from the
beginning like I'm I'm going to be a new
new me like new year, new me kind of
thing." Yeah.
>> And so, um, so I ca, we came to USA. We
came to Virginia and, um, I was so
excited like,
>> so
>> my mom was like, "Okay, I'm going to
leave you guys here. You're going to
leave here now and I want you to choose
if you want to if you're going to go to
school or you want to go or you want to
work." And so I choose to to work just
because I wanted to make money at that
point.
>> And so what grade did you finish?
>> Oh, you were a senior already, right?
>> Yeah, I finished high school. Yes. And
um but I had we in Peru we finished at
16. So I had like few like yes I had
like you know one more year to go and um
here in in in USA because I was just
turning 17. So I had one more year to go
here but I was like nah let's just go to
let's just make money like
>> and so uh after my mom left I started
working and working and working and I
was like I'm going to I'm going to just
try to be as masculine as possible. I'm
going to try my best, you know, like I
don't want people to notice. I don't
want to pass through all this again.
>> And literally the first day I got there,
people were like, "Oh, you're gay."
>> And I was so bad.
>> Yeah. Like I was trying my hardest like
like for real like even the way I walk,
the way I talk, the everything like it
was, they just notice it and they start
going crazy again. And like people, you
know, here and they were start calling
me, oh, gay, blah, blah, blah. Making
fun of me and things like that.
>> And I was so mad. I was so upset. I was
like, okay, you know what? I'm going to
stop like I can't keep pretending, you
know. And after a few months passed, I
started meeting gay people. And that's
why I believe the enemy also have
disciples, you know, like he has he
people too. And so they start bringing
me this gay world that I have always
been avoiding. And they're like, "Oh,
just accept who you are. you're not in
Peru anymore. You are in America. You
can be whoever you want to be here and
blah blah blah. All these things. And I
was like, "All right, this is good, I
guess." But at the same time,
>> I don't know. I still feel like this is
not the right thing. By this point, I
stopped going to church at all. Like, I
had, you know, no Christians friends or
anyone that was Christian. So um they
started me to invite like they started
me to tell they started inviting me to
clubs and and start drinking and things
like that. But since I was of course uh
underage I was like oh this is not like
I couldn't go until I got a fake ID and
that's when things started getting
worse. That's how the like the enemy saw
like he opened doors like immediately
for me to fall and keep falling into
sin.
>> And so I got my fake ID and I was like
okay this is going to happen. I'm going.
I'm going. I'm so excited. And so my
first like club was um uh
>> you like 17.
>> I was Yeah, I was 17 turning just 18.
>> The ID said you were 21 though.
>> Yes. No, actually it just said that I
was No, it did says No, I don't
remember.
>> Some clubs you can go to like 18. Okay.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. I think it was 18 because I
couldn't drink.
>> Yeah, I couldn't drink still. Uh, so I
just watched, it was a a gay club, so I
just watched everything around me. I see
these drag queens. I see people kissing
it like men, men kissing men, women
kissing women. And I was so shocked. I
was judging everybody cuz I was like I,
you know, like I grew up in a country
with never like this is not right.
Right. And so even though I struggled
with these things, I just started
looking at them like what are they
doing? What are they doing? Um but after
that, you know, I love I liked it
because nobody was looking at nobody
like they were minding their own
business. And so, um after that, like I
started going every single Sunday. Every
single Sunday, I started going and
going. And even though I couldn't drink,
I didn't care. I just wanted to go
>> until
it crossed to my mind, what about we
dress up?
>> What about if we can uh go back to
dressing up? Because when I was a kid, I
used to dress up as a girl. Uh with my
mom when I when my mom's uh worked and
my sister left for school, I was by
myself. So I was like, "Oh, let's dress
up." Like, so nobody's no, you know,
this was the part that nobody knew. Uh
but then I moved here and I started
seeing all these things and I'm like,
"Okay, maybe it's okay to dress up." So
I start I bought a lot of things. I
bought wigs. I bought dresses. But this
time I've been working a lot. So I make
a lot of money. And you know, as a 17
year old boy, like what are you gonna
do? Like this is money. Like let's do
this. Spend it. Let's waste it.
>> Exactly. And so I start um just um
buying clothes, buying heels, buying
everything, everything that I wanted um
until, you know, they all arrived and I
was like, "Okay, it's time. It's time.
Let's do it." And um when I wear women's
clothes and I put my wig on, I was so
like somehow happy. I guess I was so
like this is it. This is who I am. All I
could think is like finally you can be
yourself. This is going to be amazing.
Let's do it. And so
I start going out every like uh
Thursdays, Fridays, Saturdays. I started
going out like a girl like at nights
only at nights like not in the mornings
afternoon like I was a man like just
like a nor regular boy
>> h
>> and so
>> like two different lights
>> until like
>> yeah exactly that's how I felt I was
like okay this I was waiting like I
remember just um waiting like so like
impatiently just wanted to be at night I
want to go out I want to go out already
like I was already thinking what I'm
going to wear what I'm what am I going
to do with my makeup and things like
that so it was starting to get I was
starting to get more obsessed every
single time.
>> And to the point that one um I I I
became friend with a girl who uh um she
was a stripper and things like that. And
she's like, "Oh, you you know what you
should do?
>> You should start transitioning.
>> I think this is going to truly help
you." Cuz she's
>> by this time she became my really good
friend. So she started doing my makeup.
She started putting me her dresses. So I
told her everything. I was like, I just
feel so comfortable here. I don't want I
don't want the night to end, but I have
to go back to my reality.
>> Yeah.
>> And so she served me like, "Oh, let's
go." Like, uh, Planned Parenthood offers
you like you can you can take hormones.
You can be whoever you want to be. And
I'm like, "What?"
>> Cuz I'm like, "No, there what? How can
you do that?" And so she started sharing
like, "Yes, you take this. There's this
place it will give you. You just have to
go through things, but it will be all
right. You will be okay because you are
for real a woman. I can see." So when
she shared me that I was overthinking
every single day I was like should I
take it should I don't should I take it
um and my mom she moved here to USA
she's like this you know this whole
confusion uh was for about a year a year
and a half I started going out dressing
and after a year and a year and a half
my mom decided to move here and she
>> So your mom wasn't in the US she sent
you kids there
Yeah, she was she was in Peru because
she has some businesses and things like
that. So I was like so she's like,
"Okay, I'm gonna move with you guys
because you know like um especially with
me because she she felt bad to leave me
like when I was 17." She's like, "No,
maybe because in Peru like here in
America it's so like you're out."
>> Yeah. But there in Peru we're like no no
no like we take care of you like we'll
just you know until whenever you feel
ready. Sometimes you're 30 and you're
still living with your mom and that's
okay.
>> Okay. And that's just so normal. So
normal in in South America.
>> And so she felt so bad. She felt like,
"Oh my gosh, so much conviction." And
she's like, "No, my kid. How did I left
it like that?" So she came all the way
like she moved here just for me. And
she's like, "Okay, you're going to move
with me now." Because I was living with
my sister.
>> And I remember um I was at work and she
was on my room. She was sleeping at my
room. She was looking for a house so we
can move there. And um she found
everything. She found my heels. She
found my wig.
>> And I remember like just coming from
work so tired. And she's like there
staring at me in my room with all the
things in in the in the bed like my
wigs, my heels, everything was in the
bed.
>> And she just was with her face of
deception. Like I could see her face.
She was so upset. She was like, and so
she starts sharing like, why what
happened here? Like,
>> why haven't you tell me this? And so I
start crying immediately cuz I just felt
so bad. And I'm like,
>> oh what can I tell her? Like like
there's no way. There's no way out here.
And so I told her everything. I was
like, I'm sorry, mom, but this is who I
am.
>> I can't pretend to be a man anymore. And
I actually want to become a woman. And
if you accept me, great. But if you
don't accept me, I don't care because
I'm so tired of pleasing others.
>> Yeah.
>> And she was crying so bad. I
>> I feel so hor like bad for what I told
her, you know, cuz I I I know that that
wasn't right. You know, the enemy, you
definitely and my flesh like prioritize
me. Like I prioritize so much myself and
that wasn't right. Um but then after
that within time my mom starting to just
like somehow being okay with it she
actually was never okay but I she had to
accept it right and at
>> to the point that when she was like all
right you can do whatever you want to do
>> I can't force you you know I can force
you because you're an adult now
>> but you're moving with me and I want I I
want to see you like I want to see you
every day and like cuz I was like I was
going to tell my mom I'm not going to
move with you. I'm sorry, I'm 18 now.
You know, I was already with my American
mind like I'm 18. Sorry with you
anymore.
>> But um she's like, "Please, let's do let
just move with me." And so I said yes to
it. And so um after that um I start
taking hormones and I told my
>> That's such a huge step. Like I can't I
can't even imagine I'm going to start
taking this thing that's going to change
my genetic makeup. you know it's it
sounds almost like a science experiment
you know
>> so how did that how did that go like
what started happening
>> so
it was so crazy because um when I was
when I started taking hormones um I
remember uh going before I got hormones
I remember going to to to this clinic um
and they were like okay uh I hear a lot
about it I hear that before they give
you hormones you will have to go through
different steps like um some exams. They
will test you there. There will be a
um psychologist.
>> Yes, exactly. To make sure that you're
doing that that if you're truly trans
woman. And so, and they're going to have
medical things that they're going to do
to you and see if you can pass it. All
right. And so,
literally, I was like, "Okay, this is
going to be hard, but okay, let's do
it." And I arrived and the the
psychologist was trans and I remember
like well um I don't know. Yeah. Well,
this she she started like just being
like okay um um she starts telling I she
start asking me my questions about how
do I feel and things like that and I
start sharing her you know like oh I
just feel this way and blah blah blah
and
okay she was like all right just um
you're good you're good to go. uh you're
going to receive your hormones tomorrow.
>> Wow.
>> Yes.
>> I was I was crazy. I was like, "Oh, yes.
Yes. This is going to happen." And
literally the next day, uh I already had
it. I was like, "Wow, this is amazing."
>> That shows you like we are really living
in Satan's world. And there, like you
said, Satan has his disciples and
there's there's an agenda. There's a
bias. And you got, you know, the
psychologist isn't even a heterosexual
psych, you know, it's like the
psychologist is even trans. So, of
course, they're going to have a bias
towards it. Like, oh, you want to be
trans? You're definitely a woman or
whatever.
>> Wow.
>> This is right. That That's right. When I
saw it, I was like, "Oh, this is just
going to be easy, you know, cuz this
person is going to relate to me so much.
It's just going to happen." Of course.
>> Um, but definitely. So, after that, um,
I start taking hormones. I start
injecting myself every once a week and
then taking pills to stop my
testosterones. And I knew like when the
psychologist was like, uh, the are the
consequence. All right, there's
consequence when you take hormones. And
he sure like, okay, you're going to I'm
not going to be able to have kids, you
know, and um all that part of that, you
know, your part is just going to die at
one point. It's just not going to work
and things like that. And so, and after
that, after that, your liver and there's
some other stuffs, you know, and you
have to take this for your whole life.
There's not going to be a time that you
have to stop it. No, it's going to be
until you die.
>> And I was like, what? But inside of me,
I was like, it doesn't matter. Just do
it. Just take it. Who cares?
>> And and so I did it. And so, um, I start
taking hormones. And every single day,
my with my pills to stop my
testosterones.
One year passed, two years passed and I
started to see the the
um transformation. My body started to
change. I started my boobs are starting
to grow a little bit. Uh and things like
that. And I was so happy. I was like
finally this is it. This is it. This is
who I am. But not that was not only it.
Like I started having mood swings. I
started to have so much um gender
dysphoria.
>> Yeah. which I've never had but I
starting to hate myself so much of the
way I was becoming and things like that
and so that's what they don't share you
know they don't share about those things
because they only share you the good
part of like of that I guess but um
>> so after two years passed three years
passed and the hormones start to kick in
and I start getting taking uh s I start
um having surgeries so I got my breast
amentation
um I started getting like Botox all over
my face, my my my cheeks, my nose, my
lips, my my jaw. So everything like and
then after that I started doing
surgeries, BBL just to look like a
female to have the the shape of a woman
and makeup like heavy makeup all the
time and dresses that are very short and
very like you know just that shows a lot
of the way I um that that was very
provocative
>> and so to the point that people did not
realize I was trans. Um, and I was I was
when I got to that point, I was so
obsessed with myself and I started
having boyfriends, you know, and this
was what excited me the most because as
I mentioned to you, I didn't know that
um I I suffered from attention, you
know, like I struggled with these
things. So when men starting to come and
they were like, "Oh, wow, you look so
beautiful and like let's start dating
and things like that." I was so obsessed
to that world. So like I start to be man
manipulated by these men by by men. And
so when they ask me to have sex
immediately I I say yes. And so I start
falling into sexual immorality
like constantly to the point that I just
felt so used with different guys. And
>> so I'm really I got some questions about
that. These are heterosexual men that
are falling for you.
>> Uh yes actually. back.
>> I'm going to be completely honest.
This is the most believable trends I
think I've ever seen. I mean, there's
been, you know, Victoria Secret models
and stuff in real life or like I'm
talking to you right now. Very
convincing.
What? Talk about bullying. What happens
when you get into a bed with a
heterosexual man? I don't even
understand how that happens. What What
happens from there?
>> I know. I know. I A lot of people are
thinking it's
>> got to be terrifying too.
>> It is good too. Terrifying. So, um
they're ready for it.
>> Yeah.
>> I um you know this was was this was one
of the things that my mom was more
afraid of like
>> um and I think all my family because I
play with fire, you know. Um when I used
to go to clubs, you know, like people
did not recognize me at all that I was
trans or man at all. And my boys was oh
way thinner than now, like way thinner.
Um so um I had sex with them and people
are like wait what how how could you
have sex with heterosexual men like they
will go there you know and so um I just
uh knew my like I was to the point like
to the I was so obsessed with having sex
with heterosexual men because they see
me not as a trans woman or not as a man
but to that they see me fully as a woman
and that's what I wanted to achieve you
know that's what I wanted to think of me
So, um I I practice a lot like I
practice a lot to uh make my movements
right uh without them noticing what was
going on under my pants. And every time,
you know, of course, they go, "Oh, let's
have sex." I'm like, "Okay, well, we
can't do it up front cuz have my period
and things like that." And I know so it
was crazy. It was crazy. And I was like,
"I don't think they're going to buy it."
But they did. And so um you know like
within time I got better and better and
better and better and so um I stopped
being afraid of it like I just loved it.
It was like an obsession like an
addiction to just meet straight men. So
I stopped going to gay clubs. I stopped
going like I stopped you know just
identifying with LGBT community. I
actually hated it. I didn't want to
think I didn't want people to put me in
that uh in that community. Um because I
didn't identify myself anymore as a
trans. I I identify myself as a just
woman.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's when things get even like
bad. Like that's that's just really bad.
And that's how the enemy works. You
know, the demons inside are you. They're
not your friends. When they are going
the first thing they they offer me,
they're like, "Okay, why don't we just
um dress up as a woman? This is going to
help you feel better." And then after
that, oh, why don't we create this
Facebook account? That's going to
probably make you feel better. And then
after that, oh, why don't we just um
take hormones? And then you see they
they're hungry. You know, they will
never stop until they ruin you. Until
there is just destruction in your life.
>> There is a
>> there's a whole system. This is, you
know, the root of evil. The the love of
money is the root of all evil. There is
a whole system out there that prays upon
people like you were who are confused
and you know kids who don't even know
you know sometimes they feel like
they're a puppy dog or whatever are
confused and say they they feel like a
girl and then they have someone
conditioning them and and telling them
yes you are a girl
>> and because there's a whole
industry of money to be made. That's
like you said a lifetime of these pills
and shots and surgeries
that that's a you know if you're in the
medical field you want patience. You
don't that the medical field is their
mission is not to cure people. It's to
when you cure people you no longer have
a customer. You want to keep a steady
customer. And so somebody who's trans
that's that's a lifelong client.
I just wanted to throw that out there
because they they will pray on people's
mindsets like that instead of saying,
"You know what? You need to really think
about this. We need to you need to go
through therapy." And they're just like,
"Yep, you're a woman. Let's do it."
>> Yeah, that's right. It's just pure
evilness, you know,
>> and just to make money and just to, you
know, like bring destruction to this
world. It's just crazy what's going on
with this generation.
>> Yeah.
>> And um but yeah, that's what happened to
me, man. It was just so much of
craziness in my life and um it I think
like I I still can't believe you know
I'm like I'm saved and I'm here just
sharing the gospel the way I am now.
It's just amazing. That's what I'm
thinking too because
>> you know somebody like me I was never
tempted by this and I see the agendas
that are happening and I'm just like man
they're they're deceiving so many people
but now I meet you who were in it all
the way down to the surgeries and you're
young. you're 24 years old and you came
out of it and you see this is a evil
evil deception of the enemy doing this
and um you know I don't know it's just
amazing to see that there was something
that you were talking about that oh
did you ever get in any dangerous
situations where someone found out that
you weren't who they thought you were
>> all right so there is this one um I was
very very uh
I'm sorry just like I was crazy. All
right. Um
>> so I met this um
>> I was I was living in Wisconsin
>> and I I think I was yeah I was still
single by then. Um and so I remember
meeting with this like I had one of the
first times one of the first guys that I
had you know sexual encounter um he text
me after like years you know like years
I I had no I didn't know what happened
to him. And so he's like, "Oh, I live in
Texas now. We've met in in Virginia. So
I moved to Wisconsin." He moved to
Texas. And he's like, "Oh, you should
come here. Like, I paid for your ticket.
Like, I haven't seen you in forever."
>> And of course, I knew what he wanted to
do. And I was like, "All right." But he
he knew he knew that I was trans. All
right. So I was like, "All right, let's
do it. Let's go. I'll go." And literally
bought my ticket at the like the same
day. So I flew this in the same day and
to Texas and I arrived there and he
received me. And so we start talking and
then of course you know sexual encounter
happened. Uh but then the next day he
just I just he didn't want to get out of
the house and I'm like ah I came here
all the way here not to only have sex
but to you know like go out and see if
Texas what's Texas. And so um I was so
mad and so I said like you know what I'm
leaving. Bye. And uh my flight was
leaving um the next day. So I was like h
I'm not going to be here for that long
and I can't be here inside. So, I
decided to download Tinder and so I
start meeting like just scrolling around
and I met this guy. Um, and I remember
like I was like, "Okay, let's do it."
This guy of course was is a straight and
he of course didn't know. And so I
remember he just arrived into the house
and I told him like, "Oh, I have my
cousin outside, so I got to go. Thank
you for for everything and yeah,
bye-bye." And after that, of course, he
was mad, but um he let me go and I just
entered. I went out and I I saw the
truck. He was parking there and um so I
just
entered and um he's this guy who I've
never I don't I didn't even remember his
name at that point cuz I just met him
like the last 30 minutes. 30 minutes
ago. So I was like okay uh what whatever
what's so we started talking each other
to each other. Um uh he started driving.
He was like oh where do you want to go?
So I start we start going out and
different places and things like that.
And so the night like uh it started to
become it started to become um dark. So
he's like, "Oh, we should you should
come to my place. There's going to be a
party in there." So I went to the party.
We started drinking and and and and you
know um smoking weed and things like
that. And after that he's like, "Oh, you
should come to my place like to my to my
room and things like that." I'm like,
"Okay, let's do it. Why not?" Wow.
>> Um, but I didn't know that that place
that he took me was not his house. It
was actually like a different place. So
he like just took me. But this time I
was already drunk. And um he took me. So
he started driving. It was night. It was
uh um and it was so far. It was like 30
minutes. Like in in this place, you
know, Texas is just like
>> sometimes you can be you can be in the
city, but then you you can be in the
middle of nowhere.
>> Yes.
>> And so I was in the middle of nowhere. I
was like I start
>> I just look around and it was dark dark
everywhere. And so
>> and you don't have your own car.
>> I had no I have no my car wasn't there.
I had no people. My phone was like about
to die. And I was like, "Okay, if things
if something bad happened here, I'm
definitely going to die here." Like this
is just so we like he took me to his
house. There was nobody there. He lived
by himself in the middle of nowhere. And
so um he's like, "Okay, let's do it."
And so he started kissing me and things
like that. And and of course I was like,
"Okay, whatever. Since I'm here already,
let's do it." And so things got really
really bad because um I was really drunk
and I couldn't control myself. I
couldn't control my position.
>> And he grabbed me so hard and things
like that. And then he's like like he
start forcing me cuz like somehow he
start um I don't know like I was very
very more skinny than now actually. Um
so he grabbed me and like he forced me
and then somehow he's like I don't know.
I don't know if he noticed it. I don't
think he noticed it, but I don't know.
Um, and he's like looking at me because
I just didn't want I I was telling him
like, "Stop it. I don't want to do it. I
don't want to do it. I don't want to do
it anymore." Cuz he was he just wanted
to do it down there.
>> And um to the point that he was forcing
me and he is like, "Why? Why? Why you
don't want to do it? Are you trans?"
>> Wow.
>> And I was I was freaking out. I was
like,
>> "All right, all right. All right. What
do I do? What do I do?" So the only
thing that came to my mind was like no I
have my period and that was the first
time I used that that I have my period
and and I was like I I I just didn't
think that he was going to believe and
he's just like really okay let me show
me then things like that and I'm like
>> wow
>> and so I start crying
>> because I was so I was scared and he's
like but why are you crying and I'm like
no it's just not that it's just like I
so I liking him and I was like I went
through like like somebody raped me when
I was a kid and I just feel so like I I
don't feel comfortable doing this
anymore. I'm sorry. Like it's not you.
It's just like I I have so much trauma.
And so of course he felt bad
>> and he just hugged me. He's like, "Okay,
just forget about it. I'm so sorry." And
things like that.
>> Wow.
>> I I was I was so scared. Like so we
slept that night. I had no place to
sleep. So we slept together.
>> He didn't try to do anything anymore.
And then the next morning
>> u when I was getting ready cuz my flight
was about to leave and I was like,
"Please, let's go." And so he took me to
the airport and all the way um uh in the
car and um he's he's like I asked him
like do you remember what happened last
night? He's like yes. And I asked him I
have a question. I'm like what why would
it happen if I were to say that I was
trans?
>> And just in the way of laughing making
Jackson he's like oh no like if you were
to say tell me that you were trans I I
don't know what would happen to be
honest cuz I hate that. like I I am
against it
>> and
>> oh and I started laughing. I'm like okay
well I'm glad not
>> I was just it was so bad like and then
after that I was like oh he's like oh
well you know like maybe I should come
to Wisconsin to visit you and I'll stay
there for a few days. I'm like, "That's
yeah, sure. Of course, of course. Just
um you know, we can plan that later on."
After that, after I arrived to the after
I after he dropped me off in the airport
and I I start flying, I block him.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> I was so right. I was like,
>> "This was the the closest experience
I've had." And I'm so glad God protect
me because
>> otherwise I don't know where I would
end. Like, I know there's so much
craziness. I know there's so much
homophobia out there and
>> and evilness is everywhere and he had a
gun, you know, because we like we're
talking about taxes. He had guns. Yes.
>> And I'm just um I'm thankful to the Lord
because even though I was in a even
though I didn't follow him, he protected
me in this kind of situations.
>> God God knows he has got a plan for your
life. God doesn't
force himself on us. He does He gives us
free will, which is the most amazing
gift ever, but he still knows the
beginning from the end. And I can look
back and see like God preserved my life
so many times time and time again
because he knew where I was going to be
eventually.
So
>> you had this crazy promiscuous
lifestyle. You're living as a woman,
identifying completely as a woman,
uh getting some dangerous situations.
How how in the world are you to where
you're at now? What I can't even imagine
like what caused the change?
Oh yes. Well, that is so good because um
after that situation happening, uh I I
start dating. Um so I was in a
relationship for a year and a half. Now
this guy knew that I was trans. Uh he
he's straight, but within time he was
like, "Okay, let's just try it." So
>> wow.
>> He was down to doubt a trans woman. And
um
um I remember that after a year and a
half passed, we broke up because um he
wanted to have a family. He wanted to
have a a kids one day and I couldn't
offer him that, you know. And this was
not the first time that happened. Like I
had another relationship before that and
it was the same thing. We lasted for two
years and I have almost three years and
we broke up because the same situation
he wanted to have kids. I'm just curious
when you're in a a relationship like
that where it's a heterosexual male
>> with a trans woman.
>> Does anyone else know or do they think
he's in a heterosexual relationship?
>> Wow.
>> Yes. So, everybody thinks that we are in
a heterosexual like relationship. And I
remember my my last boyfriend, he was
very like like he freaked out if every
time they talk about this topic kind of
thing in front of us because he just
didn't want people to know at all. Like
not not even his parents cuz his parents
were Christians.
>> And so he was like, "No, they're going
to freak out if they if they realize
that we are that you are trans and
things like that." And I was like, "I'm
not going to tell them. Don't worry.
Like this is not going to happen." And
so that's in the bubble we were living
in, you know, and I, you know, I just I
was so confused as um and yeah, so after
we broke up, um I enter into this huge
depression like I was um to the point of
like okay, I'm pretty I I I achieved
what I wanted to achieve, but I still am
not like
>> I'm not a woman, you know? Um and and it
was and in my mind all I could think of
was like maybe if you get your bottom
surgery that will help.
>> And so I was like, "Okay, this actually
makes sense, you know, cuz if I want to
be with heterosexual men,
>> this is not going to work, you know, cuz
down there it's just not going to
happen." And so in I started thinking
about it. I started watching videos of
like trans testimonies of like doing
that bottom surgery and things like
that. And they all were saying like,
"This is so good. this feels amazing.
You can have even orgasms and things
like that. You're going to love it.
>> And I was like, "All right, this is it.
I this is my last step and I'm going to
do it." And so, um, my mom called me and
one of those days that I was going
through much depression and she's like,
"You should come to Miami." Cuz she was
she she went to Miami to to for work.
She was working for this uh old guy. Um,
she took care of him. So she's like,
"You should come here. You should move
here for a little bit. Maybe work here
while I'm gone and so you can have like
a new beginning kind of thing and get
out of that town." And so I said yes and
and I went like I literally the next day
uh to Miami and when I arrived I didn't
know the guy was rich. Like he was rich
and um when he saw me he fell in love
like he was like obsessed with me. Um,
my mom left and my mom told him that I
was trans. So, he was more obsessed
because in his mind he just wanted to
have fantasies like with me because he
had never been with a trans woman. So,
uh, we're talking about that that is 83
years old. So, he wanted to have me so
badly. And so, he started offering me a
lot of things. He's like, "Oh, here are
my my take my cards. Waste everything
that you want to like just spend your
money. Just spend the money. Spend the
money because this is what it's made
for." So,
>> wow.
>> I I was like, "Say less. Let's go." And
he lived in the richest.
>> Yeah. In the richest areas of Miami
Beach. And so
>> I miss Sorry, I missed. Who was this
connection? How'd your mom know this
guy?
>> My mom worked for as a caretaker.
>> Okay. Um Yes. So, she started working as
a caretaker for him. And um so I was
supposed to take care of him, you know,
like that just for a few months and then
my mom come back. Um and then so I was
um spending the money all like every
single day just wasting it buying clo
designing designer clothes all that I
wanted you know and going to and and
drinking and partying and all these
things starting to happen and I was like
so happy I was like yeah oh my gosh like
f like this is amazing I'm not only
pretty but also rich. So um after that
like you know if somebody offers you
something they will want something too.
So um he offered like he's like okay
well now it's my now you have to give me
something.
>> And I'm like what what do you mean? What
do you mean? And he's like and so he
offered me to have sex with him. So I
said no so many times. Um but he just
was continuously continuously like so I
did things. We had no sex but like we
just I just slow lower my slow myself um
doing another things that I just feel
uncomfortable I wasn't comfortable doing
it but um after that and he decided like
he took my freedom like he was he just
wanted me to be in his house 247 so I
just felt like I'm like like in a prison
of gold like
>> I had everything but I wasn't free So,
uh, when that happened, um, I escaped
every night. So every night I bend my
knees like I was just like going like go
to the like on the floor because it's
like he had another one
>> and so I just came very quietly just to
go out and party and drink and so cuz I
was like he lived in this area where you
literally go out and there is so many
clubs out there and it's just crazy out
there and it's like all right let's just
let's just do it and so I start drinking
and partying and smoking weed of
strangers and talking with strangers and
having sex with the strangers and in the
at the beaches of Miami Beach. And it
was so crazy because I was like every
single like I started drinking Thursday,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday, Monday. And so
I had only like two two days like where
I was sober and or three days where I
was sober. But most of the time I was so
drunk and um I arrive and I used to
arrive home and I was just in so much
depression because at this point I had
no freedom and I hated myself and even
though he gave me money and everything I
just wasn't happy and um then he started
paying for me surgeries and and this is
where crazy things happened cuz he was
about to pay my for my bottom surgery. I
was about to get my vaginalloplasty and
things like that. So,
>> yeah.
>> And I I was so obsessed with it. I was
like, "Okay, this is it. This is going
to happen." This surgery costs about 50
to 100,000. Yeah. $100,000.
So, I was like, "Yeah, I can't afford
that." So, yeah, he has to pay that.
>> And what are the chances that this guy,
this rich guy gets put in your life who
is obsessed with you and he wants you to
have that surgery so that he can have
you? I mean, what? See how Satan just
orchestrates things, man.
>> Literally. Yeah, definitely. It was uh
for me at that moment was like a
blessing, but
>> Right.
>> Definitely not.
>> You probably thought God was open doors.
>> Exactly. Right. So, so within time, you
know, that I lived there for a year for
a whole year and after the year passed,
I was already tired. I was exhausted of
him. I hated him already. I had so much
bitterness in my heart. I just wanted to
somehow
>> I wanted him to die. Yeah.
>> And um I remember that's when like God
comes like this is amazing because um
after living this life for a whole year
um I I was going on a trip to Virginia
to see my old friends and so we start
getting like we were we always smoke a
lot and things like that and I used to
visit him constantly. So they offer me
to get mushrooms to to make to to get
mushrooms and you know eat them and I
don't know if you have ever hear about
it but um they make you hallucinate and
things like that and so we sit down and
we try it and I had the worst
experience. I was literally seeing
demons and I was seeing like porn in
front of me but like not not like very
attractive porn but it was like very
disgusting porn
>> and and it was starting to become
disgusting to me. I just wanted just
like to stop watching but like somehow
like even if I closed my eyes I could
see them and I just was crying and when
no like I just wanted to stop and to
stop but it lasted for the the whole
night I could not go to sleep
>> and I remember the next day my sister
called me and she's like I received
Jesus.
>> Wow. And when she shared that,
you know, I remember I was going through
so like heavy drugs and just hearing the
name of Jesus, I was like, "What?"
>> Cuz she struggles so much with drugs,
too. She She eats a lot of gum. She used
to eat a lot of gummies and um that has
like drugs in it for her to be relaxed
>> and things like that. And so I was like,
"What? What have you done?" And she's
like, "Yeah." So she started sharing her
testimony. And when she started sharing
her testimony, I was like, "Wow, that
feels amazing." Like I started
remembering the things that I used to do
when I was um back in Peru. And even
though I didn't follow God completely, I
was still in peace somehow. Uh in
because I knew God and after that I was
like, "Oh, all right. Um okay, this is
it." because um when I was remembering
all those things immediately the
conviction of like you have to leave
everything if you want to follow God and
definitely he's not going to accept you
for who you are right now.
>> Amen.
>> And so I was like okay I'm not going to
do that. Yeah. No, there's no way. And
so I literally hang up on her and I like
all right well have a wonderful day.
Thank you so much. And I hang up on her.
Um and my friend was next to me. She's
like what happened? I'm like well my
sister gave her life to Jesus I guess.
And um would it be crazy if I give my
life to Jesus and then I turn myself
into a man again? And then we both just
start laughing so hard
>> like Yeah, that's gonna happen.
>> Yeah. And um that day I had to go back
to Miami and I remember when I was in
the flight I saw I was just looking at
my playlist and I found this Christian
song that I didn't know I had and it was
a a Christian song I used to play when I
was a kid when I was a teen in my
teenage era that actually helped me a
lot when I was struggling so much with
my depression and when people bully me a
lot. I used to play this song a lot. And
so I play it and I start crying. I was
like, "Oh gosh, no. I don't know." And
so after that, I arrived to Miami
and my sister called me again and she's
like, "I want you to move with me. I
want you to maybe go to church and try
it out. This is going to help you."
Because I called her so many times
crying with
>> and telling her my depression. Mhm. and
she's she always was like, "Oh, just
wait a little bit until you know you get
uh his inheritance and and well, he's
going to die soon and probably you're
going to get rich and things like that."
So, that's the kind of mentality she had
>> at that time. Yeah. She was all she was
all in favor of helping you become who
you felt like you needed to be and all
that.
>> Exactly. But then hearing that from her,
you know, telling me like, "You should
come here and you need help and Jesus is
the only one who can truly help you."
And I'm like, "Oh, man. What do I do?
What do I do? This sounds amazing, but
at the same time, I'm afraid because of
what I'm gonna have to leave."
>> And so I I told him I told uh the the
the old man and I just came to him and
I'm like, "Hey, um I'm thinking of
leaving.
I'm thinking of leaving probably in two
months, so you better find somebody
else."
>> Wow. Um,
I was very I was more I wanted to leave
that place not mo not because of well
just because I wanted to go to church
but more because I wanted to be free
again,
>> right?
>> I didn't want him to control me anymore.
So um I remember I had this like that
same week I had to go to Wisconsin to
visit my mom and so I flew to to
Wisconsin. So I shared that to my mom
and she was like she was in shock. She
was like what? Wait, what did you share
with her exactly?
>> She I shared her that you know I just
spoke I just spoke to me my sister Angie
and she was like and spoke to me about
like she gave her life to Jesus mom and
I don't know why but like I can stop
thinking about it
>> and
yeah
>> she didn't force me like that's what I
love my mom what she did there she
wasn't like yeah you should repent like
yeah you should go to church and like
start your new life as a man. No, no,
no, no. She was very I believe God used
her a lot in that moment.
>> I'm just like, I mean, yeah, if you
think that that could be the way, try it
out. Maybe give you an opportunity and
see how it goes. Maybe it can help you
with your depression.
>> And I'm like, um, all right, I'll think
about it. But I I little did I know is
that my mom was praying and praying
really hard just for, you know, for for
God for for me to have the encounter
with Jesus. And so, um, I left
Wisconsin. I went back to Miami. And
when I was, um, flying, uh, here, well,
to Miami, I received this email from an
audition. I was applying for becoming a
model. That that was one something that
I've desire a lot. And I've been
applying, but this time I was applying
to many, many places, but none of them
called me. And I don't know where they
uh sent me an email and they're like,
"We would love you to have an audition.
we would love to have an audition with
you, but the only place we have is in
Miami. So, I was like, "All right." So,
now looking looking back, I could see
there was two paths in front of me. The
one was from the enemy that wanted me,
you know, to be more more deep into sin
and the other one that was from God to
start a new beginning to to encounter
his presence. Um, but I didn't discern
that at that moment. So, um, I arrived
to Miami and I was like, "All right, I
want to become a model. This is my
dream. This is what I've wanted to be
always."
>> So, I'm going to become a model and then
after that, I'm going to start going to
church. Let's do that. In my So, in my
mind, makes sense. I was like, "All
right." So, I arrived to the house of
the this old guy and I told him like,
"Forget about what I said." But before I
even tell him like, "Oh, just forget
about what I said like that I was
leaving in tomorrow. I'm going to stay."
He stopped me. He's like, "Oh, there's
somebody coming tomorrow that she's
going to like somehow replace me."
>> What? Like he like he found like a
replacement that fast. And I was so so
um so in shock cuz it felt like what
have I done? Like I was just
overthinking so much. No, no, no, no,
no. I just lose my opportunity here.
Like I have to stay here if I want to
become a model. Like this is Oh gosh.
And so, um, I called my sister when I
was very anxious. I was like, "What do I
do? What do I do?" And she, the only
thing she tells me is like, "Just come
here. Like, just come here. Like, this
is where God wants you to be." And I'm
like, "This is going to be hard. I know
this is going to be so hard." And I tell
her, "Okay, okay, let's do it." And so,
um, I arrived to Jacksonville. But the
whole way from Miami to Jacksonville, I
cried a lot. And I started looking at my
ex's picture and I was like,
>> "Man, I wish I could be with him again."
Like I was I was so happy with him, but
of course in reality I was not like that
was just a huge light.
>> Yeah.
>> And so I arrived here and then she it's
amazing cuz she was used by God in a
mighty way. Um she invited me
immediately. She's like, "Okay, we have
church in two days and you better get
ready for it." So I was like, "All
right, all right. Let's do it. I'm in.
I'm in." Um, and so she started
literally like uh getting ready to
church. I was like, "What do I wear?"
Cuz all my clothes was very provocative
and I had
>> Yes. I had no church clothes. Like I was
like, "All right, what do I do? What do
I do?" And so I somehow grabbed
something and I I was very nervous. I
was so nervous. I was like, "What are
people are going to think?" I know I
don't look like a like a like a trans.
they probably they're not even going to
notice it, but if they do, they are
gonna look at me weird. And so that's
what it was running into my head the
whole way to church.
>> And so I arrived
>> and I'm I was shaking. I'm like, "Okay,
I'm going to to see you, God. I'm like,
I guess." And so I I say to myself, if
somebody sees me weird, if somebody just
even I don't know, mentions something
that I don't like, I'm not coming back
cuz I hear so much about church.
especially when I was in that community
like so much hate towards church and so
I was like all right I'm not going to if
this happens I'm leaving but um guys so
good because when I enter I just feel
very welcome like people like they
treated me like I was just like part of
the family and this girl comes to me
she's like oh my god I love your outfit
it's so beautiful like you look gorgeous
and I'm like oh thank you so I feel very
comfortable you know I know probably
didn't realize and she's like, "All
right, what?" But, you know, God used
her in that kind of way for me to be
comfortable. And
>> at that moment, I was like, "Okay, this
is it." You know, I like this church.
This is maybe a church that I want to
keep going. Um, but when I um wanted to
come closer to God, when I started
praying, uh, a church, I didn't feel his
presence. It actually felt like I was
talking to a wall.
>> And this happened for the last three
weeks. for the next three weeks, I
started going to church, but I never I
didn't feel his presence. I didn't feel
like he was there. And I was so upset
because I was like, "Okay, I thought
that I was going to have this encounter
like that I'm going to feel like, wow,
the power of God." And and it just
didn't happen. And I was like, "Okay,
whatever. Maybe he's not even real. I'm
praying and praying and he like he's not
listening."
And um I remember this uh in a regular
week on a Wednesday I there was like a
soccer game of my nephew and so I
decided to go. I still was wearing my
makeup. I had my dress very short and um
I was walking with my dog. Um and I
remember just looking at the sky and I
was like so tired of this.
I'm so tired of it. And so I started
like somehow screaming because there was
nobody there cuz um all the people were
just watching the soccer game and so I
was very far and I was like I'm so tired
of it.
>> If you're real please show it to me like
I I need you. I have tried to fill this
emptiness with so many things but I
can't I can't do this anymore. And so
when I was saying that I I felt his
presence. I felt this light this like it
was brighter than the light of the sun.
It I it feels warmer and it was amazing.
>> And I started having goosebones all over
my body. This was the first time I start
having electricity uh all the way in my
body. And I just could feel his presence
and I started crying like my I have
heavy makeup so I had like mascara and
so like all start running out I was
crying and crying. I was like and I
opened my eyes and it well I it felt
like the the scales fell from my eyes
and I I
>> I started looking at myself and I was
like I just felt like Adam and Eve when
they ate the apple and they they see
themselves naked and they feel ashamed.
>> That's what I felt. I was ashamed. I was
like, "What have I done?"
>> I started looking at my boos. I started
looking at my dress
>> and I felt so embarrassed. That was the
first time I felt like I was wearing a
costume
>> and
>> wow.
>> Immediately I ran to my sister and I'm
like I cried. I was like I don't know
what just happened but I just felt this
and she hugged me and she's like that
was the presence of God. And she hugged
me and she's like you just it's okay.
It's okay. God is with you now. Cuz by
this time, she already told me like,
"You have to set Jesus through this way.
You have to repent and believe and
things like that." So that's what I did.
And um and all I could feel in that
moment while she was hugging me was
like, "It is over. Like you're not alone
anymore. Like I'm with you. Like and
this is the beginning of a new era." And
I I didn't know what it meant at that
moment, but I can see now like I have
not like going back at all to that
world. And um since that day
>> I God has moved in a mighty way like I I
went straight to the house. Like I just
didn't want people to see me. I was so
embarrassed
to people see me that I was wearing a
costume. And so I took my makeup off
immediately. I took my dress off. I put
some baggy clothes and for the next 3
days I didn't got out of the house.
Didn't even want to get out of the bed.
And that was so like if you would have
known me by then it would be so weird
because I always every single day I did
my makeup. I did my routine my whole
routine put like my costume on and
things like that. But this time I just
didn't want to do it.
>> And so the third day happened and my
sister and I tell my sister I want to
buy men's clothes.
I I don't know, but I feel like the sire
of wearing men's clothes right now. And
so she took me to TJ Maxx and so I was
very nervous. Um, and so I grabbed some
stuffs and I went to the feeding room
and I tried a mom and I started crying
>> and I was so touched because I I was
like, "Wow, I haven't seen you in six
years
myself. Like I haven't seen myself and
my truly self, my true self." And it was
a really like it was a beautiful moment
I had that the God like put on on me you
know like so after that
um the the hardest parts comes where it
was my hair uh my hair for me was
everything my hair was really long. My
hair was my identity somehow my journey
more more of it more my journey because
it takes forever to grow. So um when I
caught it, I had I didn't uh I believe I
have manif manifestation
uh from the from the um from the enemy.
Um I was saved by the blood of God by
the by the blood of Jesus. Um but I
wasn't completely clean because I still
have so many chains like so many um
demons that I was you know like somehow
that I didn't know because I
exactly because I opened doors in so
many ways
>> and see this is a problem. Well not a
problem but I believe so many Christians
think that because you receive Jesus you
are already cleansed and saved. I mean
you are saved by the blood of Jesus
Christ. That's you have the salvation,
but you have to cleanse the temple
because all the doors you've opened. All
these demons that demons and the
enemies, they're very legalistic. They
will not leave until you close each
doors.
>> I cannot believe you're saying these
words right now. Dude, you have no idea.
This is the same stuff that me and my
wife have been studying. And the exact
words you just said that the demons are
so legalistic. that was just brought to
our mind like two days ago because the
spirit world it it is it's a it's a
judicial system and Satan has no right
to be in any of our lives until we give
him rights until we open a door and we
do it in many different ways that we are
unaware of and I say this stuff all the
time on this channel but if you have um
you know if you go to another country
and you bring home some souvenir here
and you don't know what that little
voodoo mask is or dreamcatcher or
whatever or you go to TJ Maxx and you
think this little Buddha doll just looks
so beautiful. It doesn't matter if
you're not bowing to it and not
worshiping it. You should not have that
in your home. We as as Americans, our
culture, we watch terrible things that
we shouldn't be watching. We listen to
things and we just say, "Oh, it's just
entertainment."
And uh you know, drinking and smoking
all these things. the mushrooms you were
doing, all those things are are legal
rights for Satan to come into your life.
And now
>> that's
>> I don't I don't want to say like I know
how it all works when you surrender your
life to Christ, but there is a process
that's happening. I think, you know, and
and there's still a battle for your soul
right there. And the enemy is still
like, "Well, there's an open door here,
God." And and God's saying, "Well, I'm
going to shut it, you know."
>> Wow, man. That's right. Yeah. The Bible
tells us about it. You know the Well,
it's very important that we, you know,
keep continuing um asking for knowledge
because even the Bible says like my
people lack of knowledge.
>> Jesus said it like
>> we need to be very careful with what we
watch, with what we do and uh all those
things and um make sure that we close
each doors. And so with me I had so many
doors open when I came to Christ and
that's when demons started manifesting
because during this whole years I have
never had a demonic uh manifestation or
demonic oppression or that's what I felt
because I was already with them you know
because I was already manipulated by
them
>> and so when I give my life to Jesus they
start manifesting like I start seeing
demons in my dreams demons when I when I
prayed And not only that, but then like
we start hearing like there was this
time where we were reading our Bibles in
the living room and the window started
like
like super strong and I was like okay
but you know maybe maybe something I
don't know I I was just like I'm not
going to overthink about it but it
happened three times and I when I came
out there was nothing. And after that I
came in I was like okay this is weird
but I'm not going to overthink about it
because I don't know. And we were
talking about, oh yeah, like I don't
know about God. And I remember Lucifer
came into the topic and the license
started blinking and we like I got
scared cuz I was like okay this is just
and I could feel the environment getting
heavy.
>> Yeah. And after that, that's when I got
my first uh demonic uh encounter when I
was praying and I see this huge demon in
front of me um grabbing my hands like if
I was like if he I don't know like he
was just like like with demonic pressure
like immediately I could feel that and I
opened my eyes. I stopped praying
immediately and I just like went
straight to my bed you know I was like a
Christian for like what a day. So I had
I had no knowledge. Um, and so I just
started like covering myself and I'm
like, "Okay, I don't I don't I don't
want to think about it. I don't want to
think about it." But I just the
environment got heavier and my dog start
barking at the darkness.
>> Like I just like there was so much going
on and after that we like my I came I
went straight to my sister cuz I was
shaking. I was afraid. I was like what?
Like I I didn't know I had authority
yet. Like I didn't know about when Jesus
says like you have the authority to cast
out demons. I didn't read that part yet.
So, I was like very
like, "Oh, we need to pray over that."
You know, like we have the authority cuz
she knew more.
>> So, we prayed um very like we were we
both were like somehow laying down in
bed. We prayed in her room. It just
didn't work out cuz we didn't we were
not very like putting that much of um uh
we weren't putting that much effort on
it. So, we stand up. would grab the
Bible and she's like, "This this thing
hasn't left yet and it needs to be
gone." So, she grabbed the onion oil.
>> She had more authority than me. Okay. I
was very very like
>> and I'm like I was shaking this whole
time. I was like freaking out. Oh, God.
This is so weird. This has never
happened. This never happened in my
life. And which she took me to my room
and so she started praying and uh while
she was praying she uh she just tell me
like if you feel God is leading you to
say something say it out loud and have
the authority remember what Jesus has
said and she made me read that part when
Jesus said like you know like um
>> and there's so many verses that also
says about like casting demons and
things like that and serpents and
scorpions and things like that and I was
like all right. Um, so she started
praying and praying and praying and in
the middle of her prayers I start
feeling the authority and I start
speaking out loud and I said in the name
of Jesus I cast you out whatever demon
you were here.
>> I remember I had no knowledge. So in the
middle of me casting out there's this
bright like we were praying in the in
darkness. All right. And I don't know I
don't even know why we were praying in
darkness but we didn't turn out the
light. So we was like and this bright
light comes and this was the second time
I experienced it because the first one
was when I gave my life to Jesus. So I
already knew that this was God cuz again
we both we both felt the electricity. We
felt this connection and I was like oh I
don't know what's happening. And like my
sister is like yeah I could feel it too
and we both grabbed each other. We were
like shaking and I was like, "Okay, this
is not my imagination because my sister
is feeling it too." And so this br comes
and while while while we keep praying, I
just see this demon demons around us
trying to like killed us, trying to just
like hurt us, but this bright light like
somehow like took them out like just
cast them out and they start like going
away, get running away. And
>> it was unbelievable. what I was like
what I was seeing this vision that God
gave me and I and after that the light
started going away and I was shaking I
was shaking so much I was like what what
is this what is this I had never seen a
spiritual field um in my life I had
never experienced some things like that
and I was so afraid I opened my eyes and
um my sister is like calm down calm down
this is like you know this is why we
have to keep growing Jesus because this
they will come back.
>> They will try to make us whole again but
we have to keep growing in Jesus mighty
name. And so she started anointing the
house
>> and I all I could feel is like I had so
many so many so many thoughts in my
mind. It was like was it was it true?
Was it true? What what what did I just
what what did I just see? Like is it was
it for real? Was it just my imagination?
But, you know, my sister saw it, too.
And if I tell people, they're not going
to believe it. Like, what?
And so, in that moment, I I see the
Bible in front of me, and it's like,
read it. Read it. And I'm like, okay.
So, I grab the Bible and I'm like, it'll
be crazy if God speaks to me right now
and give me some kind of like clarity.
And I see this verse which it says um uh
for what I tell you that many uh
prophets and kings will wish to see what
you have seen but they will not they
they they can't see it or they wish to
hear what you have here but they can't
hear it. Um and I hear this it just came
straight to like it was like what okay
this can be more clear this can be more
clean like what what I saw is not my
imagination it is definitely not my
imagination so after that day uh we were
very um somehow the house was very uncal
within times you know like within time
demonic things are starting to to
manifest things more doors like I
believe God start uh bringing bringing
memories
>> uh from my childhood that I didn't
remember and so I had to start closing
those doors too and start God is so good
that's what I love so much my lord Jesus
because um there's no like
>> here there's all these things you have
to clean no no no because he knows that
we are going to be overwhelmed by it but
he's just like here let's work with this
first Okay, you're good now. Like, let's
go with this one now. And so that's how
I like that was my my path. Like my
first few months as a Christian, that's
how I was like that's why I I was um I
was fully surrendered by Jesus. Like I
used to go I I I was going to church
every single day like most of the time
just to just because I wanted more my my
I want learn more about him. So, um,
God, you know, that's is why I believe
God is like opening doors for me to
share my testimony, you know, like just
putting me out there. I have never
wanted to do these things, but or never
thought this was my thing, but God is so
good and he's opening doors. And since
that day, I I realized that my my gift
is deliverance. When I received that,
I'm like, okay, this can't be my my
gift. I am afraid of that spirit. That's
what my my thoughts were in the name of
Jesus. That's not that's not me right
now. Amen.
>> And I have the authority. And so, uh,
within time, God revealed that to me.
God showed to me in different occasions.
And just this year, God spoke to me
clear like, you need to focus on this
gift cuz it'll be it will be used for
this generation. And I'm like, okay,
okay, Lord, I hear you. Let's do it. And
so I' I've been I' I just start like
learning about deliverance a lot, like
having more knowledge about it. And
literally like three weeks ago, we've
got this girl who wanted to get
delivered. And wow, like that's just
crazy because she was like this was
manifesting on her so bad. Like she
started choking herself. She started
just like crying out loud.
>> She started laughing like with evilness.
And she was going through homosexuality.
um a li a lifestyle with that and so
many other things like witchcraft and
things like that. But
>> God is so good because he prepared me
for that somehow and um we were able to
somehow cast out those demons and um we
are making a process of disciplehip.
everything that you do. Of course, I
believe God is so uh merciful because
even though I had I didn't have the
knowledge, he was there with me and the
Holy Spirit gave me the authority and um
to a to be able to do all those things.
Um but everything that you do, you you
know, keep learning, absorbing. If God
is calling you to do deliverance, keep
learning from it. Of course, the Holy
Spirit is going to use you in a mighty
way, but it's also good to absorb
everything that you can and as well if
you're doing with any prophecy and keep
practicing that, keep making that grow
because that's what we're called to do.
We are called to uh make disciples.
We're called to share the gospel to set
the people free from those bondages in
Jesus' name.
>> So, yes,
>> bro, this is so powerful. So, when did
this happen? And when did you surrender
your life to Christ?
>> It's been a year and I believe four
months.
>> A year.
>> A year and a four months.
>> Yes.
>> And God is using you in in huge ways.
And I I identify with so much what
you're saying. I never struggle with
homosexuality or trans. My journey was
totally different. But there's so many
things that you said like how God used
your sister. For me, it was my cousin.
My cousin had just become a Christian. I
was gothic and uh into witchcraft and
all this stuff and yet every, you know,
I was always a truth seeker. Uh but I
didn't think the church had the truth.
So I was going all these different ways
and I was at this like rock bottom place
like the alcohol, the sex, the drugs,
the witchcraft, none of this stuff
brings me the peace or the joy or the
hope that I'm looking for. And in that
very moment of desperate hopelessness,
my cousin comes along and I haven't seen
him in years and he's a Christian now
and he's telling me,
>> "Don't judge God by all the hypocrites
that represent him. Just read the
Bible." And I took that challenge and it
it changed my life. And um
>> Amen.
>> There's some other things you were
saying along the journey, but
>> like I always tell people, Satan doesn't
waste his energy on the lost world. He
doesn't need to attack them. the person,
the drunk that's in the bar, the
prostitute, the stripper, whatever.
Yeah.
>> He doesn't have to go after them.
They're already lost and blind. Even
your Joe, you know, Joe six-pack who
goes to work, comes home, drinks,
watches a football game, he doesn't have
to worry about them. They're not a
threat to his kingdom. When you
surrender your heart to Christ, get
ready for battle. Satan hates you.
There's a target on your head, and he's
going to do everything he can to come
against you. It says that the dragon is
wroth with the woman, the the the church
who keeps the commandments of God and
are living for him. He hates you when
you surrender your heart to Christ. And
when you want to live for him when when
I received Christ in the beginning,
there was like a battle for my soul.
When I share my testimony, I talk about
how I was walking down the hall and I
had this wave of doubt hit me like what
if this is all fake? What if none of
this is real? And the moment that seed
of doubt came to my mind, my whole body
started shaking. And I was like, "No,
no, I believe." And then instantaneous
peace would come over me. And then I'd
take another step. And this wave of
doubt would hit me and my whole body
would shake. And I'd say, "No, I
believe." And it was like this battle
between God and Satan, angels and
demons, every step of the way until I
finally just got to my bed and and
surrendered. And but it wasn't until
years later that I really like because I
was still growing. I was still learning.
I was still living like the world in a
lot of ways because I didn't know all of
God's word. But over time, I was I was
getting convicted about things in my
life. And New Year's 2013 was when I
like really surrendered everything to
God. And after that, it was like that
was the first time I ever woke up
multiple times in the middle of the
night terrified to open my eyes because
I know there's like a demon face to face
with me until I pray spiritual warfare
prayers and I say, "Get out of here in
the name of Jesus." And the moment the
name of Jesus comes out of my mouth,
that presence fleas. And uh my my
daughter, she was still in diapers at
the time. She would be looking at things
and acting weird. And
>> never had those experiences until I
fully surrendered to Christ. So get
ready when you surrender, get ready for
war. And it's a war that we need to be
in and we need to be in battle uh
armored up with the sword of the spirit
because that's the only defense we have.
We're we're battling against
evil angels where one angel in the Bible
could slay thousands of people. We are
nothing in comparison to Satan. And I it
bothers me when I hear Christians say,
"Oh, Satan, he ain't nothing. He's a
puny little thing.
He is only nothing in comparison to the
word of God. When Jesus was in the
wilderness, he was Satan was right there
tempting him. And every time, how did he
fight? It is written. It is written. It
is written. It's the sword. And without
it, we're nothing. Prayer and the word
of God claiming his promises and and
saying them out loud. That's the only
way to have victory in this spiritual
warfare. I'm so glad to hear that you
that's your calling.
is deliverance and casting out demons.
And um I know me and my wife, we have
the the spirit of discernment. We have
discernment on, you know, it's nothing
of our own. All this stuff comes from
God. And we're all different parts of
the body of Christ.
>> Amen.
>> And it's just amazing to see how we all
play a big role. We all play a role in
this big picture.
>> So good, isn't it? I just love how God
is because he's not like, hey, okay, you
know,
>> I put you here and that's it. You know,
he has a purpose for you, but not only
that, but he also like um brings you a
community, gives you the gifts of um
whichever is, but it's also it's all for
to serve um his kingdom, to bring these
people and help them to set free. And so
this is just amazing because you have a
purpose now you know like in the world
there is no such a purpose like they put
you like oh becoming millionaire or
becoming famous or becoming like
successful it is what is going to bring
you is the it is the goal right and so
many so many people go after it but when
once you're there it feels so empty and
I've been there and so
>> I'm like okay what now like
>> is that it and so but with God it's
totally different cuz he's like no I
have a big purpose for you like this
will actually make you feel like like
feel you know like the the like like
holy like perfect like it's just amazing
I don't know I don't even know how to
describe it but yeah
>> yeah we are trying to fill that hole
that God put in us to be filled with
himself and we're trying to fill it with
sex drugs alcohol music whatever and
when I was rapping and a performing
rapper on stage and stuff at the time.
It it felt amazing, but then you wake up
the next day after doing terrible things
from being drunk the night before and
all that stuff and it's just this
continual escapism. You know, you
>> you're on this endless cycle of trying
to
fulfill that hole that's in you and
nothing will fill it except him.
>> And so I'm thinking about your mom. I
have your family here. How how do they
feel about all this? And what you you've
had surgeries reversed and things like
that and thank God you didn't go through
with the bottom surgery. I'm just man,
your story is amazing to hear how God
put the right thing at the right time.
like that song on your podcast and or
the song on your playlist and your
sister calling you right when this guy
was going to provide for you to get this
>> terrible irreversible surgery
and it was like you were faced with two
roads like I I can still go this way and
even when you were tempted like I'm
going to stay for this modeling thing it
was like even that got shut down
>> because when you went back the guy
wasn't available anymore.
>> I know, right? Like the enemy was trying
his like the last thing and then God is
like, "Nope, you're coming to me." And
it's just that's why I believe that, you
know, God chooses his his warriors. God
chooses. Um, so with my family, they
when they saw this huge transformation,
I actually called my mom when I cut my
hair and when I decided to become a man,
she cried a lot.
>> She was so touched. She was so happy.
She was in joy. Um, and I was like, "All
right, this is it." You know, this is
going to be my new life. And I have to
learn how to be a man now. And and a lot
of things happened, you know, cuz I was
like, "Okay, how do I how do I even say
hi, you know, like to to a guy, to
another bro, to another dude?" Um,
>> cuz it was always like or like a hug or
a kiss because that's what we do in
Peru. Um, we kiss chicks, but it was so
normal. here is like I'm not going to do
that with another guy. Like that's just
not that's not you know that's not
right. So even with like saying hi it to
like I had to relearn and it's just
beautiful because God like um brought
the right people, brought the right
community. Um
>> they made me like learn without like
having fear or feeling like uh bullied
from the way I act or the way you know
they they never like they and that's
what I love Christian family because
They are not there to like put you down
or to tell you like, "Oh my god, you
look at you, you're so gay. You're not
going to change." But to tell you like,
"Hey, come on. Let's keep growing. You
can do it. Like, it's okay. If you fall,
keep up. If you fall, stand up and keep
growing." And so, it's just amazing.
It's encouraging. It's just like so
>> within time, God has been keeping me
like so much like so much connection
with masculine with my masculinity that
I've never had. I overthink so much of
like okay well I want to be how can I
become a strong rough man and things
like that
>> but I realized like that's not you know
like like that's that's the what the
world has labeled right
>> a man you know like that's what it is
and women are like oh you have to be
very feminine and wear makeup and things
like that and to become a woman woman
right that's what the world has labeled
men and women but in reality a man is a
one that is like like you know willing
to follow the Lord like with like being
strong enough to just keep going up to
be humble enough to go and protect their
family to be you know like there for
your family. So it's just so many things
that I've come to realize. I'm like all
right wow
>> and so it took me time. I was like all
right this is going to be a new season
definitely but God is with me. And that
is why I realized a lot during the last
year and this year where God well I
believe well when I send my life to
Jesus this was another promise he gave
me through my sister who she um I
believe that she has a gift of prophesi
prophesying and with dreams.
>> Yes. So my sister had a dream of me
having a wife and kids and with me
sharing the gospel all around the world
hear that it was like okay are you sure
like is this true? Um but of course you
know God is so good because um within
time I've been having more desires to
>> wow
>> have a wife one day and to have a kids
and he opened the door for me to share
the gospel in social media. My video my
videos of my testimony starting to blow
out like I wasn't I wasn't ready for all
these things. I've never asked him for
these things but God has been so good
and
>> Amen. like and of course now it's just
like okay wow like even just right now
thinking like that these doors are
opening I'm like wow you're amazing you
know because of the obedience in that
moment to say okay I'm giving you my
everything God has been blessing a lot
my family
and so yeah that's what's happening now
>> that is amazing because that was my next
question was have you had attraction to
women since then and all that so wow Oh
man.
>> Yes. Well, so it I always thought that
like when I when I gave my life to
Jesus, that was my first thing that I
asked the Lord. Lord, okay, I'm coming
to you now, but
>> I still struggle with this, you know? I
still like, man, and how are you going
to change that? Like
>> um I hear so many people saying like,
I'm going to go back to who I was
because you're never you're never going
to change your feelings. So, how are you
going to do that? Um but God is amazing
because um he showed me during the path
during my path the he that the healings
uh the wounds that I that I had on my
heart and that I had to be healed from
those things and God healed those areas
and within time I starting to develop
feelings towards towards women
>> and um it felt at the beginning very
like okay this is weird but I guess
I'm doing the right thing. But the enemy
used it
>> like he wanted it to make it evil again.
And why I say that um
>> when I was in the world I struggle so
much with pornography that it became
something that I watch every single day.
>> When I gave my life to Jesus and this is
where I come like where I'm being
completely honest
>> cuz it wasn't all like a fairy tale. It
wasn't all like okay since I became
perfect. No, I struggled so much with
pornography as a Christian.
>> I knew I had to stop it. Um, and I tried
to stop it. Uh, and that's when I became
that's when I realized, okay, I'm a
slave right now because I can I cannot
stop it. Like I wanted it to I I I just
have to watch it. And so, um, with like
few months happening, um, God start, you
know, developing these feelings towards
like, you know, my
women and start bringing me this somehow
feelings and so I start watching
you know porn with women and at the
beginning I start feeling like all right
this is good you know this is the way it
has to be right like I'm a normal man
now
>> yeah right
>> and in my mind all I could think is like
yes you are doing it great yes you just
have to keep watching it this is good
this is you are a man right so men watch
porn things like that and So it didn't
last that long because immediately I
showed that to my pastor and he's like
that right there you have to cut it off.
You know like the enemy is just very
strategic. He's going to tell you like a
strategic uh strate strategic strategic.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Strategic. And he's going to try
his best to make you feel that what
you're doing is right. And so um even
though you might think like oh you're
going like this is what men does it is
the same thing of like you watching men
men or gay porn
>> because you are committing like you know
what sexual immorality like
>> sexual immorality. Yeah.
>> Exactly. So um you're breaking that that
that the law of God.
>> Yeah. And so
I had to stop it and I it took me a lot
of strength and obedience
and um within time you know God set me
free from it and I can say out loud free
from pornography
amazing
>> dude this is amazing. I thank you for
being open and honest with that cuz I
know we all have our own different
struggles but me I was uh for eight and
a half years proclaiming to be a
Christian. I was
>> uh every daily drinking, smoking weed
and got to the point where I was living
with a woman I wasn't married to. all of
that saying I was a Christian, you know,
and I I literally had my cousin was
telling me that my life was blessed
because Jesus turned water into wine and
every green herb is for man and Solomon
had a thousand wives and concubines. And
it's just like, but isn't that how Satan
speaks?
>> Deception is a lot of truth with a
little bit of error. And so when when
the serpent was speaking to Eve in the
garden, he even said, "Did did God not
say you could have eat of every tree?"
Well, yeah, but when you leave the last
part off, all but this one, then it's a
complete lie. You know, it's deception.
>> Yeah.
>> And so I I lived a long a lot of years
of my Christian walk doing things that
weren't right. And I'm so thankful that
God put people in my path to inspire me
to study the word of God for myself. And
it was the word of God that changed my
life. Like I started seeing be sober
where in the last days Satan's like a
roaring lion. Be sober. Be sober. And
I'm just like I'm never sober. Like I've
been told that
>> I'm blessed by this, you know, and
and I kept trying in my own strength.
I'm not going to do it today.
Some dude knock on my door. What's up,
bro? Got some free beer and weed. And
you know, I started making excuses.
Well, I'm not paying for it and all this
stuff. But man, I was homeless by choice
for a year and I didn't go a day without
getting drunk and high. You don't have
to pay for it. You know, misery loves
company and people love to get high and
drunk with you.
>> And so I finally realized after months
of trying in my own strength that I am a
slave. I'm I'm an addict. I'm a slave.
I'm in bondage to this. and New Year's
2013 after drinking the New Year's in I
I just cried out to God and said, "I'm
weak. You are strong. I can't do this. I
I want it gone. I give you permission.
Take it out of my life." Because I
realized that God is not a thief. He
never takes anything out of your life
that you're cherishing in any kind of
way. And when I was saying, "I'm going
to cut back." I wasn't letting go. I was
still holding on. And in that moment,
God knew I was sincere and wanting to be
free forever. And I woke up the next day
without a single withdrawal.
Supernatural freedom. I had withdrawals
every day before that. Alcohol and weed.
And I was just completely free and never
went back. And that was 2013.
And so God can do miracles. It's all
really it's our will to desire to
surrender our will to Christ's will. You
know, that's what God's that's what
Jesus said in the garden. Not my will,
but your will. And so, if we live a life
like him and we surrender our will to
God, he he will give us the victory if
we ask for it and desire it and Yeah.
>> So, that that's amazing, man. It's
amazing to hear he's given you the
victory over pornography. He's given you
the victory over homosexual thoughts and
that your sisters having this prophetic
dream of you being married with kids cuz
I can see it too, man. You're a handsome
dude. You're going to God's going to
bring the right woman to you at the
right time, a godly woman, and it's just
going to be amazing. Your testimony is
just going to get better and better as
you go.
>> Thank you so much for coming on here,
man. If if somebody wanted to reach out
to you or invite you or how would they
go about finding you? I have your
website here.
>> Of course. So, we have a clothing store
uh that we've opened when I met Jesus
Christ and he put in my heart to open
this clothing up store to support the
ministry that he has for us. um um these
clothes. Well, you can see there it's um
designs that I've created myself. Um
it's so funny how that works because I
love drawing. I love designing and he
gave me this idea and I was like, "All
right, I guess let's do it." Um and it's
been working pretty good. So, um these
are the designs we've worked so hard to
do it to make it. And uh and I love what
I love of this is just like first you
share the gospel in a mighty way with a
bold design that you know helps you out
there and helps the ones that are
struggling you know
>> and also uh what by you buying a a
hoodie by you buying a a a t-shirt it
helps this ministry that God has put in
our hearts to do to help the ones that
are still lost. And um what I'm trying
to say here and I want to explain a
little bit about this is just the
ministry that God has calling us to do
is to make a place especially for the
ones that are struggling uh with
homosexuality, with drugs, with porn,
with anything that you you know from the
world and you're trying to overcome that
as a new believer. We know that it's so
hard when you are a new beginner, a new
believer, you need family, you need
community. So we want to make this place
where these kind of people where they
will leave for a few months and they
will grow in spiritual ways and develop
their gifts and also they will you know
somehow like I believe God is going to
open doors for make this happen to make
this happen for this generation
>> and this is the reason why we open the
king to somehow support us from like
financially and I believe that God will
move mighty ways. I love that design
Jesus.
It's so good. I I I was so inspired with
it and when I made it and I it's just
it's the way it just I believe it's the
story of everyone, you know, the story
of each one of us.
>> He left to to to come rescue us. So,
>> I love this shirt. I love his shirt. We
we have a lot in common, brother,
because I um when I was in the world, I
was well, I was a rapper, but I I had my
own clothing line, and I still make
t-shirts, too. And this is
>> All right. Praise God.
>> This is one I got here.
God's not done.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah.
>> And so I I want to get one of these
shirts. And if you if you like this
shirt, man, I'll send you one of these,
too.
>> Yeah, of course. If you like my shirt,
too. You know, I can
>> I'm going to I'm going to sponsor you,
brother. I'm going to I'm going to pay
for it. But um so I know you have the
the clothing line. I found this on my
own. I don't know if um is this just
like a landing page for all your
connections?
>> Yeah.
Yeah. So, our YouTube channel isn't
there. Uh is isn't isn't there? Yes. Um
you can find us at the King Yahweh, like
a guy in Hebrew. Yeah. Right.
>> And um uh YouTube channel, Instagram is
there too. Facebook. Uh usually you can
find it as Diego Arjan, which is my name
and my last name, Arlene. If you don't
know how to pronounce it,
>> if you can find it that way, you will
find it. It's just um Yeah. And there
you will see my testimonies, what God
has been doing. And also like um I I I
also do like some um like preaching
outside um some Q&A with people that are
the clubs that are drinking and having
parties. Like we we've been doing so
much of it and I just believe that God
is keep is is in is in in so much
movement and is using us. We should keep
sharing the gospel.
>> So yes, that's my Insta. Yeah,
>> I see a lot on your Instagram. Here's
you as a kid.
Yeah, that was me as a kid when I was so
confused even though
>> Wow, man.
>> Yes, that was my baptism. And um see
that's what we're trying to build. We're
trying to build a place where you know
like um people can't feel connected, you
know, cuz I feel like most of social
media it's like many people just put so
much fakeness, put so much of like uh
perfect life, but this is the truth. You
know, we as Christians, we have to share
the truth of that is God, you know, like
um and keep sharing with boldness the
the the faith of that we have as
Christians, as believers of Christ.
>> Amen. Well, Diego, thank you so much for
coming on, man. This story was amazing.
I know God's going to continue to open
up doors for you to be on podcast and
churches and even just going out with
your ministry and and reaching people
that some other people might not ever be
able to reach. You know, even myself,
you know, that's why I love God and what
he does and how he uses us in different
ways. You know, he's I can reach people
who are been down the road of drugs and
the occult and all that stuff. And you
can reach people that are struggling
with identity and LGBTQ and all that
stuff. And I it's just amazing. I I hope
to be able to stay in touch with you
and, you know, hear about some of the
stuff that you're doing later in the
future. And like I said, I know God's
going to open up many doors for you. And
I pray that somebody here tonight that
was watching or that watches this later
is just blessed and inspired. And maybe
if they're struggling with these things
or know somebody that this will really
be what they needed to hear at just the
right time.
So,
>> Amen. Amen. Yes. I'm grateful. Thank you
so much for having me. It's a it's
always a pleasure to do, you know, God
God's will and share the gospel and
share my testimony, you know, through
what God has done in my life. It's just
amazing and he can do it. And yours,
too, if you're watching this,
definitely. Um, transformation is for
everybody. So, praise the Lord.
>> Amen. Thank you so much, man. Well,
stick around. I'm going to I'm going to
say uh hi to you after I sign off here.
If you guys were blessed by that like I
was, please give this video a thumbs up.
It really helps this video get out into
the algorithm. And what a powerful
testimony that many people need to hear.
People need to have hope, especially in
this day and age that we live in.
There's so much confusion, so much
propaganda out there, so many attacks
from the enemy from all angles. And
Diego's testimony was just so powerful
on many different levels. just to see
his journey, how God was with him every
step of the way and opening up doors for
him to be set free. And so, if you're
new to this channel, click subscribe. We
do videos like this all the time and we
don't want you to miss out on any of
those. If you would like to support this
ministry, we are completely
donationbased and if you can do that by
going to candidruth.org, we got Cash
App, Vinmozelle, PayPal, we even got
Patreon. And if you like t-shirts, we
got a lot of cool t-shirts out there
with scripture or just uh cool sayings
like it's be cool. Use your brain.
Satan's out there trying to dumb us down
because dumb people are more
controllable. But um we want to use our
brains and wake up.
And we just thank you so much. We cannot
do this without you. If you have been
supporting this ministry through
donations, we love you. We thank you.
And we honestly can't do it without you.
And we'll see you next time on Candid
Truth.